i definitely i definitely wasn't like
hey like take my money
so you ended up being within reach of
being able to invest in
right uber you knew you knew garrett and
then do you remember the first time you
heard that he was
doing this uber thing yeah i mean i
don't remember
exactly but i remember when i met him
you know uber was you know it was a
thing it wasn't obviously what it is
today
but you know i definitely i definitely
wasn't like hey like
take my money um you know i think uh
but you know i guess you live and you
learn
you live and you learn i have a friend
who uh
who you know garrett pitched him and he
was in new york city this is
you know one of the smartest guys i know
and
um garrett pitched him on the seed round
of uber and and
this is in you know in manhattan he was
just like garrett like i don't know what
you're thinking about man like
people aren't going to like press a
button like
and like a car is going to come it's
just you know you raise your hand look
at me
he raises his hand watch this watch this
bam
you know like it's about creating 10x
better product this isn't 10x
quote-unquote
yeah that's true in new york it actually
wasn't right it's just
a whole bunch of other places it was
right it's like people now with crypto
they're like
oh watch this credit card boom paid for
coffee
i'm done uh you know look at this bank
you know don't need to worry about my
money it's like well yeah but that's not
the experience for most people in most
of the world
and so maybe this doesn't solve your
problem but it's going to solve some
bodies
exactly so we know we still are you
crypto guy
am i a crypto guy i um i have some
crypto
i not enough good damn i have some
crypto i dabble i mean
my whole thing is like everyone should
have
two to five percent of their net worth
in crypto as a hedge
right i calculated the other day i think
i'm at nine percent
um because i was like am i going a
little too crazy with this but then i
was like no no it's okay it's at nine
percent that's that's except that's in
the acceptable range
i'm at seven point five percent so
it also grows right so as it grows the
thing is are you gonna sell off no
um no so yeah i'm not gonna not gonna
sell off um yeah
we'll see if this ages well this podcast
the other yeah exactly the other thing
is like pay to learn in a way right it's
like dude uh okay this is interesting
i need to get in the game i need to get
a little bit of skin in the game just to
like
be be um you know if not like sort of
driving things in that that space but at
least i'm in the passenger seat or the
back seat or the trunk
like i'm involved in the journey of
where that's going by putting a little
bit of skin in the game so i highly
recommend that too because
uh that's been my approach with a lot of
things now is just um
pay to learn right yeah i think like for
me like
i learn best when i'm just like pushed
into the ground just like push me into
the arena and like
listen like i've like i've lost a lot of
opportunity and i've learned a lot of
things and you just have to
assume that you're in it for the long
long game and like life is long
hopefully
and that you have enough it's all about
at bats like
getting at bat trying different things
you know
build good relationships in the end
you'll be fine
if you if you learn and if you have a
lot of at-bats